uh
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
uh
so
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
you're mistaken
if you think that words
will bring you closer
to the kingdom of god that's already
within your heart
[Music]
rather explore
silence
explore stillness
and in doing so when you quiet
the mind you unite
with the very kingdom of god
that was always already within your
heart
but that your mind was making
too much noise to hear
the music
come on
[Music]
every heartbeat
is already ineffable perfection
relax into the art
the very subtle
art of just
being of just
awareness
of just i am
before you color it
with experience with symbols
with describing
before you add layers of identity
and condition yourself to those layers
of
identity and then create suffering
from that
so the pure bare empty
heart beat itself awareness
being i am
itself
always already eternally
free
and then you add your layers
of identity
and you contract your energy and you
move away from the perfection that you
already are into some sort of distorted
representation
of the infinite fractal
can you get so subtle that every time
your heart beats
that you feel the perfection can you get
so
silent and so still
that you feel the perfection
that's always already there
are you always already free
or are you a slave to your own creation
to your own manipulations and
distortions
that your noisy mind
relentlessly toils you around in
is your nature freedom is your nature
perfection
if you know it then you're free
then you're enlightened
free perfection
ineffable nothingness and infinity
sought
your very existence itself is
ineffable bliss and peace
but your mind with its distortions
and its conditioning has taken you
hostage
you've become a slave
to identity
personhood of desires
of aversion
what if you are completely empty
[Music]
what if you were completely hollow
[Music]
what if you cleaned out that distorted
clogged up pipe
and if you allowed divinity
to just channel through you
what if you allowed the very sourceful
i am to channel through you
but no you don't want to die before you
die
you're attached to the identity of your
personhood
it's all of those onion layers of
conditioning
the only way to liberate yourself is to
go in
go in recognize that you
are the source of awareness and
realities
you are the big bang you're not a person
you're the big bang talking to itself
you're the big bang playing with itself
you're the big bang exploring with
itself
take that perspective stop taking the
person perspective you're killing
yourself
and killing your family you're killing
your community you're killing the world
all your suffering that you're
catalyzing
because you're stuck in personhood you
are the big bang at play with itself
every single person object experience is
all you
everything is you
and you're also the very nothingness
that gives rise to it
[Music]
do you hear the background music
the omnipresent energy
it's everywhere but do you
feel it
are you at one with it
or are you scattered as [ __ ]
every heartbeat is perfection to those
that are
sensitive enough
to know it
why
are you so arrogant
that you think that words
can take you to the nothingness that you
emerged from
isn't it common sense that you have to
shut the [ __ ]
up
you need to learn how to be silent and
still
for you to know the empty source that
you originated from
pretty common sense
still yourself
repeatedly
noisy people stay
still hone in on the breath
watch what happens
please
um
do you feel it
always already perfect
moving forward this channel is going to
be more and more
purely dedicated
to being in service to everyone that
watches
to help them feel the
already present
happiness peace
perfection
and freedom that this
already is
that we already are
so
so you have a slot
a little bit time
rather than looking at your phone
and social media
rather than filling that slot of time
with something that you have to do for
work
or a chore
what i want you to practice doing is
to just be
during that slot of time
just be
have you completely atrophied
what it means to just be to where you
don't even know what i'm talking about
if you're like what does he mean by
just be
reflect on that
that means you haven't stopped doing
for years
and you forgot how to just be
so what does that mean
stand right here
leaned up against the tree in your
neighborhood
and breathe
just breathe and enjoy
being and enjoy
being aware
and if your mind is noisy
and it's dragging you around to
different thought clouds
double down on the breath
double down on being the sky
of awareness in which the thought clouds
appear and disappear
more and more you'll create enough of a
juxtaposition where you can abide more
and more as the pure bear empty sky
in just being
so stand or sit for
a minute just breathe
if your noisy mind tries to drag you
around double down on the breath
become more and more empty of the
thought clouds and just to recognize
i exist i am
the very fact that i am
like in exodus 3 14
god telling moses i am
that i am
the very fact that i am is god
my very heartbeat itself is god
luke 17 21 the kingdom of god within you
the kingdom of god within you
tatvam asi you are that
i'm the absolute yes
you are
this is an appearance of the highest you
are the highest appearing right now
that's what this is so melt
and relax into being the absolute
melt and relax into awareness
you are the absolute observing its
creation
so just relax into being
and practice that and you'll notice more
and more
why have i atrophied my ability to just
be
do i even know how to sit on my living
room couch
without looking at my smartphone
so if the answer to that question is no
you have a problem
what's the first step
we admit that we have a problem
and that's the turn inward
and as you do that you begin
unlocking the well of honey
of peace and happiness that was always
present in your being and in your
awareness
in your very existence but that your
noisy mind
of constantly i must go do this i must
go do that
and you wonder why there's so many
mental health issues
learn to be silent learn to be still
learn to just be and in that process you
will unite
more and more with the true essence
of your non-distorted nature
hi guys
can you feel the natural
awe and peace
and happiness and bliss and joy
wonder
[Music]
of the child
[Music]
do you know how to simply stretch your
body
is your mind toiling you around so much
that you're completely neglecting your
spine
neglecting your knees neglecting your
hips
neglecting your neck neglecting your
wrists
fingers your feet maybe it's time to get
a massage
maybe it's time to go to the
chiropractor
maybe it's time to stop eating junk food
high fructose corn syrup
fast food
[Music]
maybe it's time to learn how to cook
maybe it's time to learn how to stop
watching propaganda
how to stop watching polarization
maybe it's time to stop
using social media
and maybe it's time to get really good
at learning how to hollow oneself out
how to empty oneself out
how to become a clean pipe
the flow of source the flow of the
divine
is always there you've clogged up your
pipe
with all your onion layers of
conditioning
how do you unclog empty empty yourself
out
you're not those thoughts
so what are you just being
just awareness i am-ness
that we all share that's god
and this is but a manifestation
of infinity of our true nature
for us to witness for us to explore
for us to play for us to create
i'll keep working on content that
simplifies down
a lot of what i've been uncovering
and become more purely in service to
those here
that are
seeking the peace and happiness that's
already
around their neck already in that
perfect heartbeat every
second perfection
perfection
perfection
you